-Welcome back, everybody!
We are talking
with Caroline Rhea,
who will be performing at the
Epic Events Center in Green Bay
on November 18th.
I just noticed your shirt.
Very nice.
-I identify as a witch.
-Yes, that's perfect.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's perfect for you
and for Halloween.
-I know.
-You -- obviously,
"Sabrina the Teenage Witch,"
which by the way,
should come back.
Or let's do a holiday movie.
-Yeah! Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Seriously.
Okay. Can I tell you the most
embarrassing thing
that happened today
'cause I'm so
technologically stupid?
[ Cheers ]
And I played a witch
for a long time.
-Yeah.
-So, I went to buy
Halloween candy,
and I had my credit card.
And I was trying
to figure out the machine.
And the girl said, "That's okay,
you can just tap your card."
And I went like this.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
-Oh, my God.
-I know!
-And she looked at me like,
"What? What?"
-And you're like...
-And I was like,
"It worked on 'Sabrina'
for a really long time."
[ Laughter ]
Like, I was, like,
tapping the card.
Oh, I know.
It's very embarrassing.
-I'm so psyched you're here.
And it was so fun to see you
at Dave's thing.
-You were so funny, Jimmy!
-No, you -- I was not --
-You have to get --
no, you have to do one minute
of Gilbert Gottfried.
Come on.
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-One minute!
He was so funny.
It was so good.
-[ As Gilbert Gottfried ]
"Caroline Rhea, everybody!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
Caroline Rhea.
Go see her at the
Epic Events Center in Green Bay,
on November 18th.
You are the greatest.
Thank you so much
for coming out.
-Thank you so much, Jimmy.